after a constantly changing coke-fueled
narrative the White House has finally
settled on a story as to why it could
not track down the culpable nostrils and
the official story of the failure
is that they did their best
I can't really speak to the
investigation that was done by the
Secret Service they did the best they
could to track down how it got there and
and who it might have belonged to and
they just were not able to come up with
any forensic evidence that that proves
it but of course look we take this
seriously that's not the kind of thing
we want to see happen now it did happen
in a visitor's lobby area out just just
outside the main West Wing so it was
highly trafficked area we're going to
take a look at uh at how that happened
and obviously we'll if there's things we
can do to prevent that in the future
certainly we'll do that nobody's happy
about this nobody's happy nobody is
happy about this other than Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden and the senior White House
staff and the whole Democrat Party and
all the libs
but other than that nobody's happy they
just couldn't track down the culprit the
federal government which geotracked
every single Midwestern granny who came
within 10 miles of the Capitol building
on January 6th the worst day in the
history of the Republic foreign those
investigators were unable to figure out
which of the Dozen suspects brought the
booger sugar into the most intensely
surveilled building on earth
now of course
speaking of January 6 much of the
narrative surrounding January 6th was
fiction as I learned when I flew out to
Phoenix yesterday for the first ever
sit-down interview with the horn hat guy
the so-called Q Anon Shaman since he was
released from prison but that two-hour
plus interview is coming in a couple
days there is much to get to before then
I'm Michael knowlesist Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Andrew Tate who
is Andrew Tate I don't even really know
who he is taking the World by storm as
he awaits his Fate on criminal charges
all sorts of weird sex charges in
Romania we will get to him
and why everybody is kind of wrong about
Andrew Tay we will get to that in just a
moment first though
I don't want to move on too fast from
the booger sugar
I know I've only covered it every day
for like two weeks I feel like there's a
lot more to say about this there is a
lot more to say about about all of this
the way the federal government conducts
investigations a lot more to say about
January 6th I I flew out that might be
why I look a little bit sleepier today I
flew out to Phoenix to interview Jacob
chansley the Q Anon Shaman the horn hat
guy I had to fly out to him because he
is not allowed to leave the state of
Arizona so usually for the Michael and
long interview series we fly people over
here and it's nice and easy but I
thought look I've never seen a long form
interview with this guy he hasn't sat
down with anyone since he got out of
prison he was in prison for something
like 41 months so we went out there
we're gonna get that out within the next
couple of days I promise you we will get
it out faster than the Secret Service
gets you the culprit for the booger
sugar in the white house there's a
report now out of the White House
friends
that contradicts the U.S Secret Service
on this so the Secret Service said that
there were no fingerprints on the bag of
coke which was obviously a lie and at
the very least I'm sure there were nose
prints so they could have tried to match
that but there were obviously
fingerprints too and now reportedly
officials at the white house uh no who
brought the coke into the White House
and have confirmed that finding via
fingerprint analysis this according to a
report it came out just a few days ago
sofmag.com
according to a security source told
Soldier of Fortune we know who handled
it we've known since last week so
somebody's lying and probably a number
of people are lying and that's just the
way it goes
that is just the way it goes around here
we know that the White House is
deceitful we know that the libs are
deceitful not exactly a dog bites a man
bites dog story rather this is very much
a dog bites mankind of a story okay
beyond the deceit though
beyond the lies beyond the obfuscation
there is something perhaps even more
worrisome about this Administration
which is it's gross incompetence
it's one thing to be an evil genius
villain that is deceiving everybody it's
another to just not have control over
anything and that's
that's perhaps more of what we're seeing
out of the Biden Administration there's
a report came out yesterday that the
Biden Administration has leaked millions
of U.S military emails to an ally of
Russia
and do you know how they did it it's not
because there's a pro-russia guy
embedded in the administration it's not
because of some super duper spy hack
that came out of the Kremlin it's
because that Russia Ally is the nation
of Mali the African nation of Mali and
Military email addresses and with the
suffix dot mil
and the nation of mali's email addresses
and with the suffix dot ml
no I and when people type in
military email addresses they sometimes
forget to put the eye just to typo
and and there have been cyber security
professionals who have warned the White
House in fairness to Biden for some
years now something like 10 years and
the government just doesn't do anything
about it so millions of American
Military emails
you can't even say they get leaked to a
Russia Ally they're just directly sent
to a Russia Ally because we won't change
our freaking email addresses that is how
incompetent the government is so the
problem was identified by this guy
Johannes zorbier who is a Dutch internet
entrepreneur entrepreneur
he has a contract to manage mali's
National domain dot ml and he's been
collecting these misdirected emails
since January and he's been trying to
convince the US government to take it
seriously he apparently holds about 117
000 misdirected messages just this one
guy alone since January almost 1 000
arrived last Wednesday just just on last
Wednesday so he writes this letter to
the U.S he says the risk is real could
be exploited by adversaries of the U.S
well this guy's contract with the
country of Mali is about to run out and
the Malian authorities are now going to
have access to all of the misdirected
U.S military emails this is one of the
the Lesser discussed downsides of evil
and vice in a decadent Society
is that it makes you dumb and
incompetent
not just that it makes you bad and nasty
and lustful and
lazy and nasty and selfish ingredient
all these things it also just makes you
dumb and stupid and ineffective
because you get really puffed up on
yourself you fall into the vice of Pride
because you get lazy you fall into the
device of sloth and you just don't do
anything and then your your own people
send millions of emails to your Nations
adversaries
it it would be comforting and I guess
this is where so-called conspiracy
theories come from it would be
comforting in a way if we had super
duper Evil Geniuses who were extremely
competent and efficient running things
because at least somebody effective
would be in charge
but but unfortunately for us
we've got all the wickedness all the
vice all of the decadence all of the
debauchery and corruption in our
government and we don't even get the
confidence
they're not even all that clever
they're just lazy and prideful and
greedy when Joe Biden engages in
corruption it's not even some brilliant
amazing 27 degree chest corruption it's
his degenerate drug addict son just
texting apparatchics of the Communist
Party in China and oligarchs in Ukraine
saying give me money I'm with my Dad I'm
giving 10 to the big guy give me that
money now and then Joe Biden shows up
and he says hey if you don't give me
that money if you don't stop
investigating my son and all that money
you're giving him I'm gonna get your guy
I'm gonna I'm gonna withhold a billion
dollars I'm gonna fire your prosecutor
duh give me the money
it's so plotting it's so stupid it's so
pedestrian and prosaic
not very healthy for our country now
when you want to preserve your health
you want good health care you got to
check out Samaritan Ministries right now
head on over to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care and
how's it working out for you if it's
working perfectly great if not then
listen closely because I've got a
solution for you a Biblical solution
called Samaritan Ministries Samaritan
Ministries is a community of Christians
paying each other's medical bills it's
affordable health care sharing and
because it's not Insurance there are no
restrictive networks here is how it
works when a medical need arises you
choose the health care provider that's
right for you and have a say in the
treatment you receive send your medical
bills to Samaritan Ministries and they
will notify fellow members to pray for
you and send money directly to you to
help you pay those bills it could be
more affordable than what you're paying
now and if it's the right fit you can
join anytime even today check it out at
Samaritan Ministries dot org slash
Knowles kwles that is
samaritanministries dot org slash
Knowles
knowns today
speaking of vice and rotate briefly the
most Googled man in the world has gone
viral many times he's a pickup artist
type guy who the right sort of likes
because he sometimes says things that
are not politically correct and that
irritate liberals
and feminists and all of the people we
like to irritate
but some people on the right
myself included have always been a
little skeptical of the guy and pointed
out that he's literally a pimp and
that's not great that's not very
conducive to Virtue so Andrew Tate sat
down with Tucker Carlson to insist that
he's not really a pimp and my friendlies
wheeler over there juxtaposed his
interview with Tucker with other things
that he has said openly on camera and
makes it seem as though either Andrew
Tate is suffering from a very serious
bout of Amnesia or he lied to Tucker
are they accusing you of using violence
or no
you're accusing me of using the Loverboy
method coercing them by being nice I
don't mention webcam
until after I've had sex with the girl
if you're on dates and you're trying to
mention it it just doesn't work it puts
them off I'd never do that that's
disgusting I'm not a it's just not
gonna work
you continue as normal no mention of
webcam you girl after a girl you do the
PHD test so yeah on corporate.com I have
my PhD program and that is a PhD is uh
Pimpin hoe's degree that I'm
[Music]
um
that teaches basically how I bought
girls
how I met girls how I got girls to like
me how I got girls to fall in love with
me to work on webcam for me
so to Tucker Andrew Tate says look man I
never seduced women and and manipulated
them into working for me I that's what
they're accusing me of but that isn't
that so crazy and then as Liz points out
he said many times publicly that this is
exactly what he did and he says it in in
really gross ways now the defense of
Andrew Tate right now is that he didn't
rape any women
as as he is charged as having done he he
did not human traffic women exactly or
if he did he did it with their consent
that none of this was
coercive
the best defense that Andrew Tate has
right now which he sometimes makes that
recently has been trying not to make is
that he didn't rape the girls he just
seduced them
and the irony of this argument
is that a more civilized place and age
in Western
history
considered seduction to be the more
Grievous offense
we don't do that now now people think
that's absolutely crazy to suggest such
a thing
but you see this in one of the great
works of Western writing this would be
the murder of
eratosthenese by lysius good old ancient
Greek who points out that the Athenian
laws considered seduction to be far
worse far more Grievous than rape this
is not to downplay how serious and awful
rape is it's to point out that seduction
is much worse than a lot of people today
think that it is because rape is a
violation of the body
a very awful one and we can treat that
very seriously by the law it's a very
awful one seduction is a violation not
only of the body but of the soul and the
intellect so in that way it pierces much
deeper and you hear the way that this
guy describes what he does to these
women
and it seems darker crueler
more nefarious
than some mere Street Thug brutalizing a
woman's body because what he's saying is
oh yeah I tricked them I trick them into
liking me and to mistakenly believing
that I love them and so these women
they're probably a little bit damaged if
they're going to fall for these tricks
they they just want to please me and
then what I do is I use their love for
me
as a way to make money
so I don't really love them I just lie
I'm I'm a fraud I deceive them I think
of Dante Dante in The Divine Comedy he
puts fraudsters in pretty much the
deepest circles of hell and in fact he
has those who who betray their
benefactors in the very bottom pit of
Hell yeah that's what I do and why do I
do that well I do that so that I can get
more green paper and buy more stuff
very very dark
ER even than some Thug who lurks around
back alleys waiting to brutalize a
woman's body so the best defense that
Andrew Tate has here to me is the
greatest indictment of him now
does that mean that that what's
happening to end routine in Romania is
fair game
maybe it is I don't know it's pretty
dodgy that the guys in Romania running
this Big Pimpin business right so maybe
it is I don't know what the guy's up to
I have really no particular desire to
defend him the the defense the
semi-defense that I could see for Andrew
Tate is that
why aren't we going after the head of
PornHub
Mind geek which is the parent company
that owns the biggest porn site on the
internet why aren't we going after the
head of only fans
the best defense of Andrew Tate is that
this guy is some low-level Street pimp
and that that the establishment and the
law are going after this low-level
Street Pimp Like A guy who's peddling
dime bags on on Skid Row when they're
totally letting the cartel off the hook
Andrew Tate has made a lot of money and
he's become popular and he's become
controversial
but he's made no money compared to the
big guys compared to Pornhub compared to
only fans compared to the big corporate
face of exploiting women and seducing
them into this lifestyle that's depraved
and damaging to them
so
I guess my argument then isn't that we
should not go after Andrew Tate my
argument is that we should go after all
those big guys too and start imprisoning
pornographers as we have done
very recently don't forget at the end of
the Bush Administration George W bush
not even H.W bush the most recent Bush
Administration we in the United States
imprisoned a pornographer
for obscenity that's it he didn't
produce child pornography he didn't
produce any other kind of illegal
pornography
it was just pornography and pornography
can be prosecuted as illegal in itself
because we still have laws on the books
against obscenity even though we don't
enforce them very often
and we know that this is terrible for
men men are hooked on this stuff
it's it's a more powerful and prevalent
drug than any other drug in the country
pornography and we know that this is
really damaging to women
and now we've got this guy Andrew Tate
on camera bragging about how he seduces
and exploits these women and in many
ways ruins their lives
so
I guess we should go after all of them
shouldn't we not just Andrew Tate not
just the two-bit guys in Eastern Europe
how about we go after the big ones too
and how about we reread some of those
great works that formed the Western mind
and remember that life isn't just about
stuff the the people who are going after
Tate merely as a rapist or something
which I don't I don't know if that
charge is true or not but the people
going after him in that way
they're falling into the same error that
Andrew Tate is falling into which is
they think that life is all about stuff
they've fallen into a materialist error
where they think that what will make
them happy is having a lot of money and
having a lot of fancy cars and having a
lot of expensive clothing when it won't
that is ultimately unsatisfying because
those things are ephemeral those things
are just made of matter and matter is
going to Decay and the things that it
really matter to us ultimately are
things that are going to survive this
this little world toys and trinkets and
money and jewelry ultimately is not
going to be satisfying what is going to
be satisfying and lead to human
flourishing is going to be virtue the
practice of virtue in this life and
salvation in that we will get the hymnt
up in this life and and see the fruits
of in the life to come that's what's
going to make you happy we used to
understand that for most of our
civilization when we were rising and
thriving and smart and strong and now
we're depraved and decadent and we don't
know how to talk to one another anymore
we we don't know which end is up and
we've got Coke all over the White House
and and even people on the right
sometimes fall for this stuff not smart
you do not want to fall for it now
speaking of weird sex stuff a former
Google exec
has a vision
of how love will soon be redesigned
and the way love will be redesigned is
not in in a a reconfiguring of how the
Sexes relate to one another and it's not
even in a reconfiguring of how we're
going to meet one another on dating apps
and we're going to to date and get
married
the way that love is going to be
redesigned
is when we're all just doing weird stuff
with sex robots
sooner
apparently then we think now when you
want to hire people to do jobs that have
other people don't want to do you should
go check out ZipRecruiter right now go
to ziprecruiter.com if you are hiring
you're probably dealing with economic
uncertainty by definition now more than
ever it is important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully
ZipRecruiter is a hiring partner that is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
zip recruiters smart technology
identifies the best matches for your job
and lets you invite candidates that you
really want to apply to your job before
other businesses can snag them I
absolutely love how straightforward
their pricing is you know what you pay
for before posting your job so you can
stick to your budget with no surprises
hire the best with the help of a partner
that is all about you with the zip
recruiter four out of five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
I want to talk to you about something
that I don't I don't usually talk about
and that of course would be hair not my
hair
not this quaff that you look at every
day this shimmering shiny fluffy quaff
brought about by Jeremy's razor shampoo
and conditioner no I want to talk about
your hair because if you are not also
using Jeremy's restorative tea tree and
argan oil blend to wash your Mane you're
doing it wrong you're asking to be
canceled Jeremy's razors is more than a
razor company it's a Men's Grooming
brand that does not hate men imagine
that their shampoo and conditioner along
with their exfoliating charcoal body
wash are all made from high quality
natural ingredients right here in the
USA they're sulfate free and even though
I still don't know what a paraben is
nobody does they're free of all those
too most important of all Jeremy's
razors hair and body bundles are woke
free 100 stop giving your money to woke
companies that hate your guts head on
over to jeremy'srazors.com instead and
check out their shampoo conditioner and
body wash bundles today
former Chief business officer for Google
X MO goddat
has just explained
that we're all about to be
doing really weird stuff with sex robots
just think about all of the illusions
that were now unable to decipher but if
we can convince you that this sex robot
robot is alive or that sex experience in
a in a virtual reality headset or an
augmented reality headset is alive is it
real then there you go go a few a few
years further and think of neurolink and
other ways of connecting directly to
your nervous system and why would you
need another being in the first place
and once again
there is that huge debate of are they
sentient or not
does it really matter if they're
simulating syntheism so well
okay does it really matter if the Morgan
Freeman talking to you on the screen is
actually Morgan Freeman or an AI
generated
Avatar if you're if you're convinced
that it is Morgan free we get lost in
those conversations of you know are they
alive are they sentient doesn't matter
if if my brain believes they are they
are let's just say this is a very
significant redesign of society it's a
very significant redesign of love and
relationships and because there is money
in it
what would what would prevent the next
dating app from giving you avatars to
date a lot of people will try it there
are more than two two million people on
replica
does it really matter
yes
oh okay never mind then it does it does
really matter he's raising these
questions as they should be raised he
says look this is going to happen very
quickly we're developing this technology
quickly he says there are two million
people on replica which I assume is some
weird modern
robot sex technology thing I'm just
guessing I don't I don't know if any of
my producers are sufficiently degenerate
please let me know in my ears if that's
what it is but he's talking about all
this technology saying yeah it's gonna
it's going to advance to the point that
from dating apps because there's money
in it they're going to give you avatars
to date and if the person seems real
who cares whether or not he or she is
real
to which I would say uh I care
and you care and and we all care because
this is not a new debate this is a very
old debate this is a debate perhaps most
famously or infamously expressed in the
question that Pontius Pilate poses to
Christ during the passion which is what
is truth
Christ says I am truth and Pontius
Pilate a cynic
shrugs his shoulders and says what is
truth
and now we're being presented with that
choice increasingly today does it matter
if you're living in lies and deceit and
Illusions so long as the lies and deceit
and Illusions are sufficiently
convincing and persuasive
does it matter that they're not actually
true
the answer is yes
it does matter because
there is such a thing as reality we
actually have a reason
we actually have moral conscience we
actually have a soul that will outlive
our mortal coil we actually will face a
final judgment and we actually have the
prospect of Life Everlasting now I know
that there are going to be some
secularists and materialists and Libs in
the audience believe it or not we
actually have Libs who listen to the
show I appreciate them very much who are
going to say no we don't really have any
of that the soul is made up and there's
no such thing as heaven or eternal life
and so it doesn't matter as long as I
can just kind of feel good for the whole
time that I'm on Earth then when someday
I die I'm just gonna go take a dirt nap
and turn to worm food and that's it's
not going to matter whether I believed
true things all that's going to matter
is whether I felt pleasure during my
life and so for those people it won't
matter to them if they're dating a real
human being or if they're dating a robot
or an avatar or a sex doll or anything
else because it's all just about them
but if you
have any even remotely sophisticated
view of the world and you recognize that
that uh unlike five-year-olds and and in
their view of the world if you have
matured beyond that and you realize that
life is actually not just all about you
and it's about other people and it's
about things outside of you and the Very
fact that we're using language right now
to communicate means that there's an
objective reality to which we're
pointing you're going to say no I don't
want to marry a robot I don't want to
marry some stupid Avatar I don't want to
do weird stuff with that thing that the
Google guy is suggesting that I do I'm
not going to plug myself into the Matrix
I don't want any of that I want reality
even if reality is moment to moment less
pleasurable I still would prefer it
the the part that the conservatives
don't want to Grapple with the part that
the people who agree with everything I
just said don't want to Grapple with is
sex robots are going to be really
tempting
they're going to be really do not
underestimate how hot the sex robots are
going to be they're going to be super
duper hot and they're going to be
designed by Geniuses they're probably
going to be designed by robots
themselves to appeal to every base
desire that you have in a way that you
cannot even imagine right now
and it's going to be very hard to resist
them
in a similar way that it is difficult to
resist porn
there are
many conservatives in the country there
are many Christians and people who have
a relatively traditional insane view of
religion in the country
and yet porn uses through the roof
that the median age of exposure to porn
is something like 11 years old
and
what north of 70 percent of the
population regularly consumes porn of
men I think the number is like 90
percent
well a huge portion of those men and the
population generally are going to be
conservatives and Christians and people
who
in their intellect don't think the porn
is good but who nevertheless look at it
because it's so tempting and if you
think some glittering images on a
computer screen are tempting imagine
when there is just a robot that is
designed to appeal to all of your
Sensations and your whole body we have
to think about these things now when we
have to take this Google Guy seriously
now had
the American people had people in the
west taken porn seriously while it was
being developed we would not be in quite
the sexual mess that we're in right now
which you can see expressed throughout
all sorts of pathologies and ideologies
that have pervaded our society and are
driving us all crazy
and and to be fair to the American
people we actually did try to take it
seriously we passed two laws about it
with Republican and Democrat support
passed by a republican Congress signed
into law by Bill Clinton the child
online protection act and the
communications decency act both of which
were broadly struck down by liberals on
the courts so we did try we failed and
now we've got this crazy sex stuff all
over Society we've got to start planning
now everyone thinks that we've got a
we've got a plan to stop Terminator
robots from going around and shooting
all of us no we gotta stop the Honeypot
robots from coming into our Boudoir and
giving us massages and distracting us
from normal life that's that poses a far
greater risk of destroying the human
race and the future Generations then
Terminator robot which could be
dangerous too some say the world will
end in fire some say in ice speaking of
weird sex stuff
[Music]
stronger with you
as the political order breaks down you
want some stability especially for your
assets when you want that stability when
you want something real and hard and
tangible you're probably going to want
to check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days away
from the Durbin Accords the greatest
threat to the U.S dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S dollar as Cornerstone
of the Global Financial system you can
protect your IRA or 401K from The
Fallout from this Landmark Announcement
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold historically gold has been a safe
haven in times of high uncertainty which
would be right now when currencies fail
gold is that safe haven how much more
time does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers text
nulls Canon wlas to 98 98 98 get your
free info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on text null scanner WLS to 98 98 98
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Johnny
vermon6305 who says Michael getting
muted when he mentions certain facts is
infuriating shaking my head I totally
agree with you Ben when especially when
you're watching this on YouTube you're
gonna see certain words get bleeped out
you're going to see segments of the show
believed out you probably noticed that
the show has gotten shorter if you watch
on YouTube the show hasn't gotten
shorter I don't actually censor myself
but if you want to watch the full show
you got to do it at Daily wire plus we
are now putting the full show up for
free at Daily wire plus but with ads now
if you want to watch the full show
without ads with the member segment with
all the extra bonus stuff that we don't
get to elsewhere and then you join daily
wire plus if you want the full show
uncensored if you want to just listen to
it you go to the RSS feed Apple podcast
Spotify Stitcher Google Play wherever
else and if you want to watch the whole
show you can also go to Twitter at M
knoll's show but as long as you're here
on YouTube
we
acknowledge
we're forced to acknowledge at Google's
and YouTube's rules for what we can say
and so sometimes there are certain true
things that you're just not allowed to
say
you got to go elsewhere to find it now
speaking of
big Libs
the head
of the Nea National Education
Association one of these big teacher
unions This Woman's name is Rebecca
Pringle
she's a graduate of the University of
Pittsburgh that is the school of course
that tried to shut me down and at which
the libs tried to murder me somewhat
recently gives you a little a hint of
her intellectual formation and academic
background the Nea president has this to
say
about the future of American Education
I can hear
Chase Seattle
crying out to us
urging us to remember
when you know who you are when your
mission is clear
and you burn with the inner fire of an
unbreakable will
no cold can touch your heart no Deluge
can dampen your purpose and yay you are
the stars in the darkness your light
will not be them your purpose will drive
you in our right chest fight for freedom
because you know who you are
now I know that we have a number of
viewers and listeners to this show in
Central Europe so I'll translate that
speech
is
I
don't usually make that sort of a
comparison but if you were only
listening to it
you just you can't fully appreciate how
this woman in some ways looks a little
different from a certain Austrian
painter and 20th Century political
leader but in other ways she's got the
short cropped hair she's gotten the
hands and the passion she even talks
about the will the will will win out our
Wills that are you suggesting a phrase
such as perhaps the Triumph of the
willow lady or are you it just
seems a little
over the top
and this woman
is a major leader of Education in
America
perhaps the best advertisement for
homeschooling I have ever seen as this
woman falls into an occult ecstasy
also yeah also kind of weird occult
ideas that the parallels between a
certain historical phenomenon that I I
don't usually compare things to and
these modern lives especially in
education quite striking and and so you
look at that and you say goodness
gracious this woman is has no control
over herself that's the point of
education is to control yourself is to
be brought up learn how to behave learn
how to discipline those those lower
passions and to bring them into Accord
with the rational will and also to know
things to this gets back to what we're
talking to at the top of the show that
yes we have deceit and Corruption and
vice and all this nasty stuff in our
political order but but one of the
Lesser discussed consequences of that is
just sheer incompetence and you see this
expressed in our educational apparatus
the the teachers and the administrators
especially
broadly speaking cannot teach things
they can't teach math they can't teach
reading
they can't teach basic life skills
they go off in these Flights of Fancy
about whatever struggles this lady has
dealt with in her life but but they
can't they can't actually do the basic
elements of the job and you're seeing
this everywhere goodness gracious there
was a a
really pathetic story out of New York
New York City is paying two billion
dollars to black people
New York City specifically is paying two
billion dollars to black people who
performed poorly on an old teaching exam
Hispanic people too they wanted to
become teachers and they took this exam
and they failed and they sued and they
said this exam is racist and so they
didn't they didn't become teachers a lot
of them New York City is going to pay
two billion dollars to them
some people who never worked as a
teacher will get more than one million
dollars each
that they could even get pensions as a
result of this which will inflate the
cost beyond the 1.8 billion dollars that
the post is reporting 64 year old
Hermann Grimm
will be paid 2 million fifty five
thousand three hundred eighty three
dollars after failing this test a lot
because supposedly the test was racist
this guy Hermann Grimm was asked how is
the test racist he couldn't say
he has no examples
he failed the test a lot he's probably
not good at coming up with answers here
but he is pretty good at making two
million bucks and you want to know the
cherry on top of this story
they remade the test
it's no longer racist the test now
totally woke liberal politically correct
Progressive racism free
the scores didn't improve
the the
black people performed poorly on that
exam too
why is that I don't know why you'll have
hear some people say oh it's because
black people are terrible you might hear
some people say well it's because they
the the people who took this test they
didn't have a good educational
background they might say well they
didn't have a good social background and
so they just didn't have the ability to
prepare for this test in the same way
that other people did
I don't know I don't know why the the
Black and Hispanic test takers didn't do
as well on the old test and the new test
I don't know it's not my particular
subject area of Interest I leave it to
other people to to figure it out here's
the one thing I do know
it
it wasn't because the old test was
racist we've now proven that because of
the new test
and yet two billion dollars from New
York City taxpayers still going to these
people
which is a reminder that we talk a lot
about reparations this is the new
radical liberal proposal is to resurrect
the idea of reparations for slavery
centuries after the fact but we have
reparations this is a type of
reparations this is a an expression of
how in the United States if you can
claim that something is racist you can
get whatever you want
this is why this cognitive language is
bandied about this is why it's the worst
thing that you can possibly be called in
modern America is to be called a racist
it's why people throw it around totally
baselessly I remember David Webb the
black conservative commentator he was
hosting a radio show this is some years
ago now and a woman called in they were
debating an issue he was winning the
debate and she said well you only think
that because of your white privilege
it was a radio interview as a phoner so
she didn't she didn't know and even
Webby says you know
I'm pretty sure it's not and I don't
think he would say that if we were on TV
right now and he totally got her but she
didn't care she just she just wanted
some excuse just like these people and I
guess good on them these people who just
got paid two billion dollars over
nothing
I guess good on him because they gained
the system
but that kind of a system is not going
to be able to persist forever in part
because it encourages selfishness and
pride and greed and vice and Corruption
among the people but also in part
because
we can't do the basic stuff that a
society is supposed to do
because we've we're lowering standards
needlessly because we can't teach we can
adjudicate teachers we can't
run the government we can't conduct
investigations we can't get the economy
to work we can't conduct foreign policy
we just can't do stuff from we can't
reason about these things
I keep going back to this and rotate
example
the fact that our moral discourse on the
right and the left has has boiled down
to this
significant But ultimately relatively
small question of hey do people consent
do those girls consent to be pimped out
by Andrew Tate well then it's it's
totally fine hey did do people consent
to all sorts of weird sex stuff in
America and including children oh then
it's totally fine isn't there something
a little bit deeper we used to have
moral discourse we used to have the
ability to reason about these things
as that Ebbs away so Ebbs away our
civilization well cease to be civilized
will become barbarous materialists
howling into the wind the rest of the
show continues now
today of course
is Tuesday
it is
Tuesday we can't talk about it on
YouTube you got to go to the member
block head on over now to dailywire.com
use code Knowles for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]
oh